you uh put up this tribute to taylor
hawkins who just died from the foo
fighters way too young uh it's very
upsetting on your drum you have a
picture and i had taylor on the show
many times i just thought he was the
loveliest guy
yeah very upsetting that's a nice
tribute i mean i don't how many times in
your career have you put a picture of
somebody on your drum
uh not too many you know i mean
uh
i love taylor
he was one of my best friends
um
yeah it's it's uh it's
it's i'm just we're still shocked and
and so saddened by his passing
um yeah he loved you howard he was he
was like um
he's like you know kind of tough he's no
no no he's great and howard's great
he always asks like really good
questions smart guys fun you should do
it you should do it i was like well okay
but he did
yeah well and he loved life you know and
and he um
was a real beacon and and full of
positive energy um
i'm gonna miss him so much you know he
was he's a godfather to my son beckett
and
um you know we spent a lot of time
together these guys loved them too we
toured a lot back in the
late 90s and 2000s played a lot of shows
with the food fighters and
um you know i love his family and and
just trying to be there for him on every
the outpouring from everywhere
you know not only musicians but but
people all over walks of life
showed how much he was so um
loved and
um yeah when i asked him to be my son's
godfather i said uh taylor can you do
you think you'd be the godfather to
beckett and he goes
yeah of course yeah
well
um you know yeah what do i got to do i
go i i don't i think you know
not really anything he was okay great i
can do that
i'm good at that you know but he was
beautiful and i'm gonna you know we're
all gonna miss him and
um so yeah just you know a little
tribute and and um
you know i love him